we got movies we got books we got nacho
cheese does it make sense it Wilson plus
we are joined by writer producer
director and movie lover John Campea and
this is no you obviously from you
started AMC movie talk and you took that
on to Collider movie talk yeah recently
you announce your resignation and you're
on to do other things first can you tell
us a little bit why you decided to move
on and then what you're working on next
I've always wanted to kind of bring
sports fanatics enthusiasm to the world
the movie phantom and hence we created
movie talk stuff like that but I've been
doing that for about seven years I'm
gonna be producing a few more shows
coming up here pretty soon but we
haven't announced yet we're gonna be
announcing that pretty soon I'm gonna be
just do something with our friend Jon
Schnepp I get just got a lot of things
coming up so I needed more time what
would you say is one of your favorite
movies that you've seen recently
Deadpool I mean that movie came out of
nowhere and just shock the hell out of
me and then just recently I saw them
well why it's cuz he's Canadian and also
you know having a good Canadian kid in
the opening and I lived in Saskatchewan
for a while you love the wick I love the
wind I thought I was going in to watch
one thing yeah and it turned out to be
completely different than what I thought
there is something that you have going
on that's really exciting yeah fantasy
genre to me is something I love you
wrote a novel in that genre called the
price I was shooting a movie about seven
years ago and I camp the idea for the
pride I started working on it five years
ago it's a story about a race of dragons
that wakes up with total amnesia they
have no idea who they are where they
came from what they are and then it fast
forwards to modern-day Los Angeles with
a young guy and who discovers his
connection to that ancient race the
official release date for the book and
paperback audio book and Kindle is
Monday the 29th of February alright so
check out the pride that comes out
February 29th get it yeah but I got to
ask you John what is your pick for it
the best picture I think the film this
has all the momentum right now spotlight
when you look at a film that was so
masterfully put together the acting
ensemble I think is the best out of any
film this year even more than say the
big short or something like that it's
just an incredibly well-done story so
you've got your mad max's you've got
your revenants you've got your the big
shorts but i think it's gonna be
spotlights here
gonna pics you know can't pick you cuz
this weekly wager once again last week
we got on the movie race Tiffany what
about last week
I bet 12 million in Christian bet 9.5
and the actual box office for the movie
race is 7.3 which means once again you
are this week's loser should comes from
youtube user pyroblast 3000 who says
loser should wear rain boots filled with
nacho cheese dip let's prep for the
cheese boots
it's Christian's queso real nacho cheese
and it is time for John to pour it into
this boot off this is about eight grand
in concessions Tiffany if you please put
your foot in the cheese and why tiffany
you lose all dignity we are going to be
talking about next week's wager and it
is all about Eddie Eagle all right John
who do you think will win Tiffany wins
this week action great Superbowl ad
tracking well looks good it's gonna be
higher people have bet against me before
oh no make sure you submit your loser
shreds using the hashtag in the YouTube
comments
pull leg up use the hashtag loser should
have in comments below on Facebook and
on Twitter so it's stuff that Christian
has to do please it is today's John we
spoke a little bit about which movies
you like to like the Deadpool you like
the wish which movies that have not been
released
well there's the ones that the near
community is all looking forward to
including me you got Batman V Superman
you got Captain America Civil War you've
got Doctor Strange if you like that
obviously Star Wars to come up again at
the end of the year with rogue one but
come
none nerd once I'm really looking
forward to one the nice skies Ryan
Gosling Russell Crowe directed by Shane
Black who directed Iron Man 3 as well
and then the free state of Jones I think
looks amazing with Matthew McConaughey
could be his next Academy Award
nomination give them in there mmm
glad I'm providing dipping sauce for
your snack Jungle Book every time we see
trailers for that one I'm blown away and
then we excited for what is it clover
lane turn 10 Cloverfield Lane I feel
like two different trailers totally
different have no idea what to expect
really this is so gross you want to get
on board well get ready to move time to
play dream time this game is called book
or both I'm gonna give you guys a title
and you have to tell me if it is a movie
book or both use your buzzer pepper
buzzes and first gives the correct
answer earns a point all right are you
guys ready first up a Scanner Darkly
movie both OH
all right our next one is sunshine movie
that is correct one two one okay
Northern Lights both you would be
correct the movie was actually followed
by Golden Compass
300 boom that is correct
the last one is labyrinth just a movie
you are incorrect come on Oh is both
there's a yep here's the wheel John it
is see it is here it is do you spin the
wheel decides all right here we go
[Music]
here alright alright John you got ten
seconds to ramp right into that camera
the floor is yours all right in every
civilized country in the world movie
theaters have pre assigned seating where
you can pick your seat that you sit in
you get that our airlines concerts
theater whatever you want why don't we
have in every movie theater in America
agree it was great I totally agree
because then I could have my seat
assigned and then I can go get as much
nacho cheese as I was yes you're
starting to like it now sell those
cheeses best all right John well I just
want to say a huge thank you for coming
on the show you guys make sure you check
out his book on February 29th the pride
and follow him on social media at John
Campea can't pay John that's a giant ape
you don't you all right another great
show make sure if you guys want to see
even more hopefully first in doing
terrible things with a loser should
click right over there and subscribe
that's right and check out more past
episodes right over here a movie
threesome and make sure you download the
Fandango movie clips app on your
smartphone and join us every week on
[Music]
you